- On this episode I'm
live-streaming while I'm doing
the episode, and I answer questions about
the new YO app and a couple other things
that I can't remember now.
(upbeat music)
(audience cheering)
You ask questions, and I answer them.
This is the #AskGaryVee Show.
Hey everybody, this is Gary Vay-ner-chuk,
and you're watching and
listening to Episode 76
of the #AskGaryVee Show.
Speaking of listening, I want to,
as a matter of fact,
this is actually perfect.
I'm actually live-streaming a meerkat?
Is that? Mer-kat? I gotta hit up the,
I know the guys, we're
actually looking at it.
We may even invest in it,
it's pretty interesting.
Anyway, we're streaming
live, so I'll actually
talk to you guys as well at Meerkat.
I'm looking for people to
leave reviews to the podcast
of the #AskGaryVee Show,
so all of you listening
to the show right now,
one thing I realized
that I need to do to bump it up,
so this is not a question of the day,
this is a request of the day.
Can we get a Request of the Day look?
You gotta give me credit for 76 episodes,
and I think I did one or two others,
but the request of the day is,
if you are listening to this,
especially on iTunes, by the way,
thrilled to get one star
and you saying the show
sucks crap balls, that's
fine, I respect that.
But the review itself actually matters,
and so VaynerNation,
please hook me up there,
Meerkat Mafia.
(laughing)
Get in here.
And that's that.
I had a great weekend, spent a ton of time
with the kids, it was phenomenal.
Re-posted the Monday
motivational video this morning.
I think I'm just gonna
do that every Monday.
Though, DRock, do you
think we should tape
an original Monday motivational video
every Monday on that corner?
I kind of think there's something there.
So if I'm around next Monday, am I?
If I'm around next Monday,
let's just do another one.
I think we should just do
it, and I'll just do new
versions of being angry at people
that are not happy about their Monday.
Are you in my calendar yet?
Am I here? I'm in Vegas?
All right, that's good.
But I'm available the
next following Monday,
so we'll do it the 16th.
Let's get into the show.
- [Voiceover] Jason asks,
"How do you know how much time
to give to clouds versus dirt?
Is it based off your
personality and strengths?
Example, if you're gifted
to lead and set the vision,
should you spend less time doing the work
even though you also like it just as much?"
- The clouds and dirt
debate is a super tough one.
Obviously for people that follow me,
DRock, that was really
just you, take the credit.
DRock made an incredible film,
let's actually link that up
right here, or take over, I don't know
what you do these days.
It's just really my thesis
of how I build businesses,
how I live life, right?
Focus on the big big big
things, but don't get scared
to get your hands dirty,
'cause execution matters.
Ideas are shit without the
execution, and vice versa.
Don't play in the middle,
that's the real concern.
And so I think you need a healthy balance.
To me, I can give you a good answer here.
This is one man's humble opinion,
I'm uncomfortable if you
go 70-30 in any direction.
If you're over-indexing
70 or 30 in any direction,
that's a problem to me.
So stick to minimum 70-30 clouds and dirt.
Yes, I do think you can map your DNA
if you're a big thinker, big time thinker,
finding where I place 70 there,
still have the humility
and the practicioner skills
to bang out a 30% here.
If you don't think
you're as big of an idea,
you think you're grinding and
your hustle is a big factor,
or there's an ebb and flow,
like sometimes I'm in 70-30 mode, and then
I'm in 30-70 mode because the 70 was right
and now I have to execute.
As a matter of fact, right
now, I feel with VaynerMedia,
the last nine months I was 70 execution,
but I'm feeling myself moving up to like
90 thinking, 10 execution,
because I need to re-chart
the course of the company
because I'm seeing
not vulnerabilities,
I'm seeing opportunity,
and that puts me on the offense.
So I don't think there's a
perfect breakdown of clouds
and dirt, they just
always need to be in play,
and really I don't think of
them as a day to day basis,
I think of them more
holistically as a true commitment
both to strategy and
the dirt that you need
under your fingernails in execution.
Way too many primadonnas right now,
I'm the thinker.
Think this.
- Hey Gary Vee.
Big Ed Barnum here from Big Ed Barnum's
Bubble Barn and Garden with an important
question for you: If my right hook is
Watch my web series, what
are some appropriate,
I should have stretched.
Uh, jabs?
- Actually, you know what Staphon,
why don't you do a little
walk around the office
right now, this way
they'll miss this question
so that will make them
have to watch it later
and then they can also see
a bunch of Vayner stuff.
Big Ed, first and foremost,
as a hardcore WWF, not E,
fan growing up, you feel like a wrestler,
and this is a wrestler promo,
and that feels amazing to me.
I just love that.
You know what's so funny?
That's what I want.
I want people to go to GaryVaynerchuk.com.
I want that, and I want
people watching my content.
Get in here, Staphon.
And I want those same things, and so
I think that content
itself is the jab, right?
Put out micro pieces of content.
I'm a big believer, I think
that I'm hitting a golden era
in my content production.
Live streaming, my Snapchat
Stories game is up,
my Instagram game is up, my
Twitter's still on point,
my Facebook fan page content is up,
LinkedIn is stronger than it was before.
Pinterest we're still lagging.
When you can really get our
Pinterest game up, right?
- [Steve] It'll happen
for Wine Library I think.
- I know, but we're talking
about me now, not Wine Library.
Pinterest needs to get up a little bit,
but you need to put out micro contents.
The reason I wrote
"Jab, Jab, Jab, Right Hook"
is to get you to put out
different little pieces of content
that still thematically ladder back up
to what you're doing on your website
that are contextual for the platform.
Big Ed, don't get lazy on me.
You're Big Ed.
Go out there and put out
content across the board,
and don't just make it,
remember, the jabs need to be jabs.
Don't just make the
content where you're like,
my biggest idea ever is, dot
dot dot, go to my website.
Your website will get
traffic as a byproduct,
and you were able to throw right hooks
on those social platforms,
but put out jabs of value
to the audience where they
actually spend their time.
Big Ed, they love you and they
want to go to your website,
but they'd rather, more
than being on your website,
be in all these other places,
and it's up to you to be there
and use that as a gateway
drug to get them back.
(upbeat music)
- [Voiceover] Laurie asks,
"When you have a new
idea for your business,
how long does it take you to implement?
Do you run with it?
Strategize for a while?
Consult with others?"
- Laurie, this is really interesting
because I've actually lived
this now in my 39 and a
half years of my life.
I'm getting close to 40, boy
it's starting to freak with me.
Look, there's been businesses
that I've sat on in my mind
for such a long time
before they get executed.
Years, sometimes, even, as
they marinate and get refined.
Then there's me and
Jerome Jarre have dinner,
and literally the next
day there's Grape Story
and we have a talent agency
representing Vine celebrities.
So to me they've run both of the gamuts.
Me and AJ spent nine,
10, 11, 12 months trying
to figure out what we were gonna do.
Little known fact, before
starting VaynerMedia
we were probably on third base on starting
a fantasy sports site,
which would have probably
been a good idea, or a
deal of the day site,
which would have also been a good idea
as that was the early days
of Groupon and Living Social.
So we picked the wrong
one, but we marinated.
Maybe it didn't come out
as good as we wanted.
But we'll take Vayner
as a consolation prize.
Really I think it comes down to the idea,
it comes down to the timing.
I've got ideas that are
running through my head now,
bad timing, I'm running too much stuff,
I'm doing too many things at once.
This whole content team was probably,
I don't know, how long
was I talking to you
before we even started?
How long was it being flirted about,
or was that just in my own mind?
- [Steve] Six months, but it was just
you and me for like a year.
- No I know, but before
it was just me and you,
how long was that, like hey Steve,
I'm thinking about something?
- [Steve] Six months.
- Yeah, it was six months
before we literally,
and that probably means
12 months, and Steve started for a year,
and then it started rolling
with all the other characters.
So I just think it comes down to the idea,
but more importantly for me,
because I'm always rolling
with ideas, it's the timing.
Am I prepared?
Don't forget, I've often
answered that the biggest
failures in my business career have been
when I've bit off more than I can chew.
I'm in the process of it right now.
FaithBox, Resy, VaynerRSE,
Brave, VaynerMedia,
my personal brand, there's
a lot going on right now
and I'm trying to hold up all these balls,
and we'll see what happens.
- Hey Gary Vee, it's your
old friend Nicole Lapin.
Not old like that. Don't get crazy.
Here's my question: Why do you think men
should aspire to date a rich bitch?
- Hey Nicole, big shout out to you.
I know your book's out.
I took this question because
you are an old great friend
and I wanted to give
exposure to your new book,
so DRock, let's link that up.
I know you're doing super
well with your book,
and I think we talked a little bit about,
the book is about really
financial stability
and financial smarts, I
think, that a man should
marry a rich bitch or
be in that situation,
or a woman should marry a rich bitch dude
for the same reasons that,
having a stable financial partner
is always a good decision in life.
People that are unable
to manage their money
deal with so much stress, and money is not
the most important thing,
but when you don't know
how to handle that, there's
an enormous amount of stress
that comes along in life, and it's not
about how much you make.
There's plenty of people
who know how to manage
their money making $37,000 a year
and have a lot less stress than people
that make $140,000 a year
and don't know how to manage.
To me, I'm anti-stress.
Money management is at
the tippy top of the list,
probably right below the health
and well-being of family,
and that would be the core reason.
- Yo, Gary Vee.
What do you think of the
new and improved YO app?
Is it worth it for my small business,
food drug and restaurant to get
this deliciousness out into the world?
Answer my question.
Thank you, and keep hustlin'.
- Greek Mike, great question.
Shit answer, which is, I haven't looked
at the new and improved YO app,
thus I can't give you a real answer.
I'm not even really sure
why I've even accepted
the question knowing that
my answer was such crap.
It was probably mainly
because I loved the video
and wanted to give you the
exposure and the shout out
that comes along with being on the show,
but it also gives me an
opportunity to kind of
answer the question as a whole, which is,
look, communicating,
I have a phone call, what time, right now?
Yeah, all right, I need to
run, 'cause this is super
important, let me just wrap this up.
At the end of the day,
communicating with your audience
is the number one thing
that you should be doing
at all times, and if you feel
like the YO app brings you
value and your audience
value, then you should do it.
You should do that, you should do Meerkat,
Snapchat, Instagram, Twitter,
Tumblr, Pinterest, Facebook.
Whatever you think actually communicates
and has an ROI that's time
that you put against it
to communicate about the exposure
of eating a beautiful gyro, do that.
Question of the day:
How many siblings do you have,
and what are their names?
I like mine, that's why
I want that question.
You keep asking questions,
I'll keep answering them.
Staphon, what are they saying in there?
- [Staphon] They're
like what are you doing,
what are you filming?
(laughing)
What's going on with
the chat, they like it?
- [Staphon] They want to know
how you feel about Meerkat.
- Well I don't know yet, it's early.
I'm just feeling it out.
Is it pronounced meerkat?
- [Steve] It's like
the animal, like Timon
from Timon and Pumba.
- Is that a meerkat?
- [Group] Yeah.
- That's an actual thing?
- [Steve] That's an animal.
- That wasn't them like, there's no names,
let's come up with something?
I swear on the Jets, I've
never heard of meerkat.
- [Voiceover] Look at their logo,
their logo is a meerkat.
- How many people have
heard of a meerkat before?
Aw, fuck, all right guys.
Guess I didn't see that Disney movie.
Let's move on.
Steve's a little rusty.
I get it, I get it, but I
want the whole thing, go ahead.
I don't need it for that,
but I need it for this.
- [Steve] Got it.
- This is prime time.
- [Steve] For example,
if you're gifted
to lead and set the vision,
- No don't do that,
'cause then my bald spot.
Just kidding.
(upbeat music)